phoenix persönlich völlig persönlich
heute vom rheinufer in bonn hier in bonn
arbeitet und lebt einer der
renommiertesten virologen in deutschland
professor hendrik speck chef der
virologie an der universitätsklinik hier
in bonn und autor der vieldiskutierten
heinsberg studie über die wir uns gleich
noch ein bisschen ausführlicher
unterhalten wollen wir haben uns hier
verabredet in einem gartenrestaurant das
noch geschlossen ist für gäste aber ab
montag dürfen in nordrhein-westfalen
restaurants eröffnen wie fast überall in
deutschland sonst schon platz reserviert
im restaurant ja leider noch nicht aber
ich freue mich meine ich selber kochen
zu müssen und mal wieder auf gutes essen
wie beurteilen sie den insgesamt diese
lockerungen sind die in ordnung oder
geht das alles jetzt plötzlich viel zu
schnell
ja ich denke es ist wichtig dass man
sich jetzt diesen weg gefunden hat den
ich im übrigen sehr smart findet dass
man nur ja das regional herunterbricht
auf kleinere bereiche auf kleinere
städte und das ist ein guter weg glaube
ich wo wir wo wir das virus gut
kontrollieren können wie gehen sie denn
persönlich mit dieser krise um sind sie
sehr sehr vorsichtig oder sagen sie das
kann man ein bisschen lockerer angehen
ja also ich hab die selber nichts sorge
in vielem ich zu infizieren aber ich
mache mir natürlich sorgen um einige
mitmenschen und die auch älter sind und
vorerkrankungen haben zum beispiel aus
meiner familie war noch ältere menschen
infiziert mit profit 19
da habe ich mir schon sorgen gemacht und
die hatten zum glück aber ein sehr
milden verlauf lassen sie uns über ihre
studie reden was genau haben sie
untersucht
nun wir sind nach gangelt rein gegangen
weil wir da einsam ausbruchs ereignis
hatten also ein super spreading muss man
vielleicht erzählen das ist die gemeinde
mit deutschlands berühmtester
karnevalssitzung ganz genau und auf
dieser karnevalssitzung haben sich sehr
viele menschen wahrscheinlich infiziert
und danach garbsen
sehr großen anstieg von neuinfektionen
wodurch die shutdown maßnahmen und die
ausgangs beschränkung das wieder runter
gefahren wurde und das war für uns
ideale szenario um dort die dunkelziffer
zu bestimmen was haben sie denn jetzt
genau herausgefunden
also wir haben herausgefunden dass in
der gemeinde gangelt 15 prozent der
einwohner infiziert waren oder sind mit
saas kopf 2 das ist ein relativ hoher
wert im fast fünfmal höher als was man
vorher gedacht hat in der gemeinde
gangelt und daran können wir zum
beispiel einige rechen rechnungen
aufstellen nämlich auch wie teuer wie
hoch die letalität also die infektions
digitalität des virus das heißt wie
viele oder promille von denen die
infiziert sind sterben am ende und was
haben sie daraus gekriegt und wir haben
den wert 0,37 prozent rausgekriegt also
das von allen die infiziert sind 0,37
prozent versterben das hat natürlich
auch ein fehler bereich und das
diskutieren wir in dieser publikation
aussehe
das geht runter bis zu 0 28 prozent und
hoch bis zu 0,4 1 prozent also es gibt
also ein fehler bereich aber die der
punktwert davon ist 0,37 trotzdem ist es
sehr sehr spannend denn wenn wir jetzt
die offiziellen zahlen nehmen würden das
robert-koch-institut dann müsste man
annehmen dass die sterblichkeit der
infizierten in wirklichkeit bei vier
prozent ist also zehnmal so hoch und sie
haben rausgekriegt nee die sterblichkeit
der infizierten ist also um den faktor
10 geringer
welche folgen hat das jetzt nun ich
glaube folgen erst mal gar nicht aber
man kann daran zumindest erstmal
anfangen das virus besser einzuschätzen
was bedeutet so ein virus für unsere
gesellschaft wir sagen auch nicht ist es
jetzt der wert der für alles bestimmt
ist sondern denken sogar wird er ein
bisschen niedriger sein das hat mehrere
gründe
aber das
man man kann eben damit lernen mit
diesem virus umzugehen und lernen was
diese infektionen für deutschland
bedeuten das ist das wichtige das
entscheidende ist wir haben ja bisher
schon vermutet es gibt eine gewaltige
dunkelziffer aber sie haben zum ersten
mal zahlen ermittelt übrigens zahlen die
in eine ähnliche richtung gehen wie eine
amerikanische studie die stanford studie
die hat sogar herausbekommen dass die
letalität da wo dies untersucht haben in
einem county santa clara dass die
sterblichkeit noch niedriger ist jetzt
ist ja das interessante dass sie mit
ihnen zahlen gesagt haben okay dann kann
man eine schätzung eine art hochrechnung
machen wie hoch ist denn die
dunkelziffer wie viele leute haben sich
denn in deutschland insgesamt infiziert
ja und da muss man vorsichtig sein und
das haben wir so auch wie sie es gerade
gesagt haben gesagt aber wir es wurde
zum teil ein wenig falsch verstanden
wir haben ein wert der vitalität
bestimmt von 0,37 prozent und diesen
wert kann man erst mal nehmen um
schätzungen anzustellen also das ist
wir haben ja immer modellrechnungen was
solche infektionen für deutschland
bedeuten würden und wenn man diesen
werte aus der gemeinde gangelt anwendet
auf die modelle für ganz deutschland
dann muss man damit rechnen dass so 1,8
millionen fast zwei millionen der zeit
infiziert sind aber das ist nicht ein
ein wert den wir bestimmt haben
ich versuche in meinen worten
auszudrücken wie ich glaube verstanden
zu haben was wir das gemacht haben sie
haben im galt festgestellt ok circa vier
von 1000 infizierten sterben jetzt
wissen wir ja für ganz deutschland wie
viele leute gestorben sind und wenn es
da ein ungefähr vergleichbares
verhältnis gibt dann dürften wir in
deutschland ich sag es mal ganz grob
irgendwas zwischen einer und drei
millionen infizierten haben das ist
deswegen bemerkenswert jetzt hole ich
mal wieder die offiziellen zahlen des
robert-koch-instituts raus demnach
hätten wir 170000 infizierte insgesamt
in deutschland und ihre schätzung oder
ihre berechnungen legen nahe dass das
circa zehn mal so viele sind die diese
krankheit
deutschland schon hatten da sind
gewaltige unterschied das ist ein
gewaltiger unterschied aber gar nicht so
weit davon entfernt von den wie das
robert-koch-institut wahrscheinlich
selber setzen würde ich glaube die sind
ein faktor 8 ausgegangen
wir haben jetzt einen faktor zehn es ist
natürlich ein modell wir wissen es nicht
und wir werden es wahrscheinlich auch
nie wissen würden wir nicht jeden
deutschen testen aber ist es eine eine
arbeitsgrundlage auf der wir das
irgendwie weiter arbeiten können das
sind grobe schätzungen haben sie selber
gesagt weil die basis ihrer berechnungen
ist natürlich nur eine gemeinde mit
einem besonderen geschehen und in dieser
gemeinde sind sieben später dann
insgesamt acht menschen gestorben
das heißt natürlich wenn da zwei drei
menschen mehr durch einen zufall
gestorben werden weil das virus in ein
altenheim eintritt eingebrochen ist dann
hätten wir doch eine andere letalität
zahl bekommen eine andere quote von
denen die sterben wenn sie erkannt sagt
ja aber man kann es ja auch durchrechnen
was bedeuteten acht abfall ein neunter
fall dann kommt man auf 0 41 0 44 ist
bewegt sich in einem bereich der dann
nicht über 0,6 0,9 oder zwei prozent
geht also wir wissen dass der bereich da
unten liegen muss wie genau was genau
der wert ist das wissen wir dass am ende
der ära dem i also ich halte man fest
wir haben erstmals durch ihre studie
einen vernünftigen beleg dafür wie hoch
die sterblichkeit ist und natürlich nur
ein bauchgefühl drüber was ich auch noch
interessant fand was ihr rausgekriegt
haben mehr als jeder fünfte infizierte
hat am ende gar keine symptome das heißt
der weiß gar nicht dass er diese
krankheit hat ja und das hat mich selber
auch überrascht und das ist auch etwas
was viele vermutet wurde aber genau wie
sie das eben gesagt haben es geht nicht
um das bauchgefühl sondern es geht darum
das eigentlich mal zu belegen und wenn
jeder fünfte infiziert ist und es ist
nie mitbekommen hat dass er irgendwelche
symptome gehabt hat
das hat für das hat ja eigentlich
konsequenzen weil es bedeutet dass wir
nicht immer die infektionsketten auch
überhaupt nachvollziehen können und gar
nicht wissen ob jemand infiziert ist
oder nicht und da müssen wir darüber
nachdenken ob das bedeutet dass wir sehr
viel härter und stärker testen müssen in
deutschland oder uns zurückziehen auch
wirklich die symptomatischen was wir
nämlich auch nicht wissen ob die die
keine symptome haben überhaupt das virus
übertragen können das ist ja eine sehr
interessante feststellung mit diesen
leuten die gar keine symptome entwickeln
haben sie denn irgendwelche
anhaltspunkte dafür gefunden warum die
einen sehr schwer erkranken am ende
vielleicht sogar sterben und andere
leute entwickeln nicht mal symptome
ja also das sind natürlich erstmal
mutmaßung wir haben aber einige
interessante assoziationen gesehen also
wir sehen erst mal von den infektionen
dass die gleich sind im alter und bei
kindern
wir sehen aber bei kindern eine kleine
verringerung der der infektionszahlen
also hier sind aber wir haben nicht
genug kinder eigentlich in der studie um
zu sagen ob kinder weniger infiziert
sind
auf der anderen seite sehen wir auch
dass kinder und ältere keine symptome
haben können also das ist
altersunabhängig ob jemand schwere
symptome entwickelt oder nicht das heißt
auch die vermeintliche risikogruppe
ältere menschen über über 70 kann ich
sag jetzt mal glück haben und am ende
vielleicht gar keine symptome entwickeln
aber dass da reden wir halt über die
einen und die anderen können sehr schwer
kann genau also dass das finde ich auch
sehr spannend dass ältere menschen keine
symptome haben können also das ist nicht
bedeutet man das älter und man hat eine
schwere erkrankung und es bedeutet
übrigens auch nicht man ist älter und
hat zum beispiel eine vorerkrankung und
man hat schwere symptome also auch eine
vorerkrankung prädestiniert nicht dafür
dass man unbedingt einen schweren
verlauf haben muss woran könnte es
liegen dass jetzt einer schwer erkrankt
und das ist natürlich der heilige gral
dass auch herauszufinden
unsere studie suggeriert muss man
wichtig auch sagen ist beweist nicht
aber wir sehen dass es nicht nur mehr
infektionen gegeben hat wenn man auf bei
der karnevalssitzung teilgenommen hat
sondern auch dass die symptomatik sehr
viel schwerer ist wenn man an der
karnevalssitzung gewesen ist so ist ja
karneval persönlichen anstecken sondern
allenfalls das verhalten weiners
anstecken lassen ob ihre gläser oder die
dinge die laute musik oder alle fallen
sich um den hals was könnte das sein
also wir kennen das von anderen tieren
zum beispiel von vom grippevirus und da
muss ich ein bisschen ausholen denn in
england hat man mal so ein versuch
gemacht dass man freiwilligen viren
gegeben hat mit aufsteigender viren
großes also immer mehr viren gegeben hat
und bei mehr viren wurde auch die
symptomatik stärker da gibt es einen
direkten zusammenhang zwischen der
symptomatik und wie viele viren man
abbekommen hat und wir nehmen an dass
bei so nem super special event in
gangelt bei der karnevalssitzung die
teilnehmer sehr viele viren abgekommen
haben und dadurch auch die symptomatik
schwere waren weil wir hatten vorher 22
von denen die keine symptome hatten in
ganz gangelt wenn man jetzt die dänen
beim karneval rausnimmt liegt es bei 36
prozent also fast jeder dritte hatte
keine schwere symptomatik oder hatte
keine symptomatik und dann nehmen wir
schon an dass diese infektions dosis die
die allgemein bekanntes in der virologie
ein entscheidender faktor ist wie schwer
die erkrankung verläuft und noch ein
interessantes ergebnis unter ihrer
untersuchung die ansteckungskette
innerhalb der familien also von personen
die in einem haushalt leben die ist
zumindest ich fand das überraschend
gering also weniger als die hälfte der
menschen haben sich angesteckt wenn in
der familie einer erkrankt ist wie kommt
das zustande
ja also auch da kann man nur mutmaßen
erstmal das spannende ist es gibt keinen
cluster effekt ob ein personen haushalt
zwei personen drei personen oder 4
personen haushalt
wir sehen die gleiche rate von
infektionen
das ist anders zum beispiel beim
norovirus oder rotavirus wasser über
schmierinfektionen übertragen wird da
wenn er ein erkrankt dann sind meistens
die ganze familie krank also bei hier
sehen wir eine abhängigkeit vom personen
haushalt wenn eine person im haushalt
infiziert ist dann ist die zweite person
in einem zweipersonenhaushalt häufig zu
43 prozent infiziert das liegt daran
dass das meistens pause sind und dann
auch engeren kontakt haben bei einem
drei-personen-haushalt nimmt es ab auf
rund 28 prozent und dann runter auf 18
prozent also bei vier personen haushalt
haben wir nur noch eine
wahrscheinlichkeit von 18 prozent dass
sich eine weitere person infiziert das
ich sage das jetzt mit aller vorsicht
das würde nahelegen dass die infektion
von kinder auf eltern oder von eltern
auf kinder weil das sind ja in aller
regel drei bis vier personen haushalte
eher nicht so super einfach funktioniert
das ist genau der punkt den dem man die
die an die daten suggerieren aber wir
können es nicht beweisen und das ist
immer ganz schwer in der wissenschaft
solche sachen zu beweisen aber wir sehen
keine häufung von infektionen in
familien wo kinder da sind
aber wie gesagt kinder haben darauf war
die studien nicht ausgelegt und dadurch
können wir da auch nicht keine guten
aussagen treffen jetzt merke ich ja wie
sie sehr darauf achten dass sie das
alles korrekt formulieren was man aus
ihrer studie alles ableiten kann
das liegt natürlich auch daran weil sie
doch einiges an kritik haben einstecken
müssen zunächst einmal weil sie
angeblich oder wirklich vorschnell
teilergebnisse der ihre studie
veröffentlicht haben ohne abzuwarten was
man sonst in der wissenschaftlichen
praxis macht das andere kollegen das mal
gegen ließ warum sind sie so schnell an
die öffentlichkeit gegangen nun
ich bin ja nicht nur wissenschaftler
sondern als virologe also ist man arzt
und die haben eine eigenschaft des virus
bestimmt und da sehe ich es als meine
ethische verpflichtung an diese so
schnell wie möglich unser dass wir um
dieses wissen so schnell wie möglich
teilen und dieser wert von 0,37 prozent
haben wir übrigens vor vier wochen
bereits gesagt also es war nicht etwas
was wir vorschnell an die öffentlichkeit
gegeben haben
man sieht er daran dass wir genau den
gleichen wert wieder bekommen haben bei
509 personen das dass das eine sehr gute
repräsentative studie ist weiß ich nicht
ändert in einer hohen höheren
personenzahl daher fanden wir das extrem
wichtig das mitzuteilen
und ich merke einfach dass ich rede
vorsichtig darüber
ich merke wie einige redakteure oder
aber auch zum beispiel unser endergebnis
jetzt falsch interpretiert haben und
falsch verstanden haben
weil suggeriert wird dass wir was gesagt
haben was wir nie gesagt haben und das
finde ich sehr wichtig dass man das auch
deutlich macht also ich bemühe mich
darum dass sie nicht überinterpretieren
noch noch ein vorwurf den man ihn
gemacht hat sie seien nicht
unvoreingenommen an die sache gegangen
weil einer der auftraggeber war das land
nordrhein-westfalen und wir alle wissen
ministerpräsident laschet ist er auf der
seite
lasst uns mal öffnen also waren sie
wirklich unvoreingenommen ja natürlich
war ich unter angenommen weil so eine
studie kann man gar nicht anders
durchführen als unvoreingenommen zu sein
das darf ja mal ganz kurz erklären weil
das ist wichtig dass diese studie nach
guter klinischer praxis durchgeführt
worden das ist eine nach der deklaration
von helsinki
das ist ein 1 1 vorgehensweise die
überhaupt nicht erlaubt daten zu
manipulieren zum beispiel ich als
studienleiter kann zum beispiel gar
nicht auf die dateneingabe zurückgreifen
also ich kann gar keine daten eingeben
dass es in der studienzentrale gewesen
und die datenanalyse ist im institut für
biometrie auf beiden kann ich nicht
zugreifen
damit eben genau dieses dieser punkt
nicht passiert
dass man voreingenommen an so eine
studie rankel die analyse wenn ich etwas
analysiert haben will muss sich den
statistiker fragen ob er diese analyse
durchführen will aber dass es nicht
etwas was ich selber machen kann
ich würde mich mit ihnen gern noch ein
bisschen darüber unterhalten was wir
denn generell über dieses virus wissen
fangen wir mal mit mit der allgemeinen
bemerkung an dieses virus ist so harmlos
wie krippe oder viel gefährlicher als
krippe was stimmte jetzt ja also das ist
etwas von virologe immer erst mal
schlucken muss weil dieser vergleich so
schwierig ist mit grippe eigentlich ist
es ein vergleich von äpfeln mit birnen
vor allem und das macht es so schwierig
jedes jahr haben wir ein anderes
grippevirus oder meistens ein anderes
grippevirus und dann ist die mal die
letalität sehr viel höher und x 4
niedriger die saisonale grippe
normalerweise und die in der
sterblichkeitsrate bei 0,1 prozent
und da ja wenn man davon erstmal ausgeht
ist es wichtig zu sagen dass es ein
virus was man nicht bagatellisieren darf
aber eben auch nicht überdramatisieren
sollte und wir wir haben eben andere
grippeviren dann wieder die man ver sehr
heftige pandemien auslösen können also
wir hatten den berühmten winter 2017
2018 da hat man auch kompliziert
hochgerechnet dass am ende in
deutschland 25.000 menschen glaube ich
an dieser grippe epidemie gestorben sind
in einem winter also da sind wir in etwa
sag ich mal bei den zahlen die uns jetzt
im laufe von ein paar monaten bei
sowie 19 auch drohen könnte ja wenn man
sie auf statistische bundesamt schaut
sieht man auch für 2017 2018 für den
winter wirklich ein anstieg der
todesfälle und das ist wahrscheinlich
meistens durch die grippebedingt wir
haben aber diese saisonale häufung von
todesfällen immer wieder und meistens
sind das irgendwelche grippalen infekte
wo auch coronaviren im übrigen auch zu
zählen also andere in cologne abwehren
ganz ganz interessante frage ist dieses
corona virus saisonal ich muss das mal
versuchen simpel auszudrücken lässt die
ansteckung und die sterblichkeit durch
dieses virus jetzt im sommer nach weil
das virus keinen sommer mag aus
irgendwelchen gründen und steigt das
aber dann keine entwarnung auch wieder
an im november oder dezember wenn der
nächste winter kommt ja also die
einfache antwort oder schnelle antwort
darauf ist man weiß es nicht aber wir
haben hinweise darauf dass es so sein
könnte
zum einen kennen wir ja vier corona
während die bei uns heimisch sind und
während die wir sehen das schon eine
häufung in den wintermonaten aber die
verschwinden nicht ganz in dem im sommer
die tauchen immer mal wieder punktuell
auf aber es gibt keine großen infektions
ausbrüche die sind im winter
gleichzeitig ist sehr interessant zu
beobachten australien australien
da sind nur 20 prozent der infektion in
australien übertragen wurden
80 prozent der infektionen in australien
sind im ausland erworben worden und rein
gebracht worden das was uns zeigt dass
in australien es sehr schwer wird schwer
ist dass das virus überträgt und
australien ist auf der südhalbkugel da
ist war bisher sommer und deswegen also
dass eines der indizien die darauf
hindeuten dass dieses virus saisonales
kann uns jetzt ein bisschen entspannen
lassen soll man wird vielleicht nicht so
schlimm bedeutet aber gleichzeitig
wieder das kommt halt wieder umso
schlimmer dann gegen jahresende und dass
es sehr schwer da wirklich eine
vorhersage zu machen und auch zu
spekulieren
was sein kann wir wissen es eben nicht
aber dass wir mehr gehäuft infektionen
jetzt haben werden mit einer niedrigen
infektions dosis also dass viele
menschen vielleicht eine infektion durch
machen ohne es überhaupt mitzubekommen
und daher das kann einmal durch die
hygiene regeln die wir jetzt alle
verinnerlicht haben aber auch durch die
den sommer dass wir einfach mehr auch in
die breite gehen mehr auf abstand
sowieso gehen und auch wenn tröpfchen
eurozone übertragen werden die durch die
wärme und sonne einfach kleiner sind wie
schätzen sie denn die chance ein dass
wir durch hygiene regeln durch kontakt
regeln dieses virus ganz aus der welt
schaffen ist das eine realistische
option
nein das glaube ich nicht also dass das
ich glaube dass neue corona virus wird
heimisch werden wie alle anderen oder
die vier anderen coronaviren es ist ein
virus was uns immer mal wieder plagen
wird und wir müssen eben anfang mit
diesem virus zu leben weil wie mit jedem
anderen kohona virus auch und gerade in
der anfangsphase erst jetzt ist es
wichtig dass wir eben die hygieneregeln
einhalten damit wir eine partielle
immunität in der gesellschaft erreichen
also dass das menschen immun werden ohne
schwer krank zu werden und da glaube ich
dass die hygiene wirklich ein
schlüsselelement daran das heißt aber
wenn wir dieses virus nicht mehr aus der
welt schaffen können entscheidend wird
am ende sein dass es fortschritte gibt
weil der medizin bei der behandlung von
infizierten und vielleicht eine impfung
von mama bei der medizin bei der
behandlung an also ramsey wir chloroquin
thrombose spritzen eine ganze menge
ansätze wie man einen erkranken
vielleicht behandeln kann
wie hoch ist dann die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass wir jetzt ein vernünftiges
medikament finden oder die kranken
besser behandeln und dann stirbt die
dann fällt die sterblichkeit auf die
hälfte oder gar auf ein fünftel oder
sowas und wir sind dann am ende doch
wieder bei der gefährlichkeit einer
normalen sind
grippe auch das ist sehr schwer
vorherzusagen wir gegen einige viren
haben wir einfach probleme gute
antivirale medikamente zu finden
das was was aber nicht heißt dass wir
das jetzt sehr schnell finden können
rennen die sie wir scheinen effekt zu
haben aber wir müssen eben gute studien
erst mal abwarten die das beweisen das
problem ist eben es geht nicht darum es
zu glauben oder das gefühl zu haben dass
es wirkt sondern wir müssen beweisen
dass es wirklich einen vorteil hat und
wenn man einmal einen ansatzpunkt hat
nämlich ende in der wissenschaft dann
ist es auch einfacher den zu verbessern
und zu versuchen okay wir können dieses
medikament noch besser machen noch
effektiver machen
das hat man sehr gut bei hiv gesehen
dass mein mann hatte den ersten
ansatzpunkt und danach kam ein
medikament nach dem anderen schönes
stichwort denn hiv also die
aids-forschung das war ihr bisheriger
schwerpunkt damit lasse ich jetzt mal
über auf die impfstoff entwicklung also
da sind sie ja in einem feld wo man da
gar keine hoffnung machen kann
die aids epidemie gibt es 30 40 jahren
und wir haben immer noch keinen
impfstoff wie groß ist denn die gefahr
dass wir in 10 20 jahren immer noch
keinen impfstoff gegen korona an
ja also man kann einfach bei
impfstoffforschung keine vorhersage
machen also einfach nur ein historisches
beispiel in ein nachdem man das hi virus
entdeckt hatte trat margaret heckler in
den usa vor die kamera die aus dem
gesundheitsministerium hat gesagt und
zwei jahren haben wir einen impfstoff
und wir sind jetzt viele viele jahre
später haben wir immer noch keinen
impfstoff im übrigen auch nicht für
hepatitis c malaria tuberkulose das sind
alles ja erkrankungen die die menschheit
plagen aber wir haben kein impfstoff
gefunden also da eine seriöse vorhersage
zu machen ist hart ich nehme an dass das
mit dem corona virus leichter sein wird
einen impfstoff zu finden aber man muss
auch bedenken gegen die anderen sechs
coronaviren die die menschheit immer mal
wieder plagen oder
den menschen derzeit befallen können
haben wir auch noch keinen impfstoff
und da vorherzusagen dass es jetzt
klappt gegen dieses an diesem einen
corona virus einen impfstoff zu finden
ist schwierig das heißt wir müssen unter
umständen noch lange vielleicht sogar
jahre mit diesem corona virus leben
kommt wieder auf die aids forschung
zurück das ist ja genau das selbe wie
wir das jetzt mit aids erlebt hat wir
haben es gelernt mit diesem virus dass
wir nicht ausrotten können zu leben was
was kann man denn aus der aids-forschung
lernen um mit diesem corona virus
adäquat umzugehen
nun er erstmal das hi virus ist fast
immer tödlich
ohne behandlung das neue corona virus
saß cause 2 ist fast immer nicht tödlich
und das ist glaube ich ein
entscheidender unterschied dass dass man
die nicht direkt gegenüberstehen kann
ich sehe ist sehr kritisch an
ein immunitätsgesetz ausweis zu haben
weil wir kennen das aus dem hiv bereich
dass man am anfang darüber diskutiert
hat ein hiv pass zu haben oder die zu
kennzeichnen dass sie positiv sind da
kann eine unheimliche stigmatisierung
und diskriminierung losgehen die an hiv
bereich wirklich sehr stark immer noch
ist von hiv-infizierten was wir denn
überhaupt ob wir in immun sind wenn wir
konermann hatten auch das wissen wir
noch nicht wie wir können ja nur so
lange zurückblicken wie wir das neue
corona wir es kennen und das ist ja noch
nicht sehr lange
aber wir kennen die anderen coronaviren
und da bildet sich so eine partielle
immunität aus also die die menschen sind
vielleicht nicht ganz geschützt können
dann nochmal sich infizieren
aber dann mit einem sehr sehr milden
oder symptomatischen verlauf
virusforschung findet im normalfall ich
will jetzt nicht abwerten aber eher im
verborgenen statt das hat sich plötzlich
völlig gewandelt also virologen sind
plötzlich bekannt wie schauspieler die
politiker
auf ihre rat wie gehen sie denn mit der
neuen rolle um
ja also eigentlich
es war am anfang hat mich das selber
auch überrascht dass man dass man das
dass das so eine popularität bekommt
aber ich gehe gar nicht anders damit um
als ich sonst mein leben geführt habe
ich glaube ich habe das erste mal in
meinem leben gefühlt mitgekriegt dass
ich wirklich in zeitprobleme komme und
auch die nacht nicht mehr ausreicht um
dinge zu bewerkstelligen und dazu gehört
natürlich auch
presseanfragen aber die ich eigentlich
zum größten im moment absage weil ich
was gegen die pandemie beitragen will
und nicht in talkshows sitzen will
wie sind sie überhaupt auf die idee
gekommen die raw logik zu werden also
worin besteht denn das glücksgefühl wenn
man sich tagaus tagein mit sowas
unangenehmen wie infektionen und etwa
termingeschäfte
ja ich muss sagen ich bin da
reingerutscht ich wollte ursprünglich ja
filmmusikkomponist werden und habe auch
musikwissenschaften und bwl studiert
weil ich eben so einen musikproduzenten
richtung erst dann gehen wollte die ich
fing an an in einer praxis blut von
hiv-infizierten abzunehmen und dann im
namen ist so seinen lauf dass ich meine
doktorarbeit darüber gemacht habe dann
in boston an der harvard medical school
assistant professor geworden bin und
dann am ende johns hopkins und militär
hiv-impfstoff forschung gemacht habe wo
ich dann meinen facharzt für virologie
angeschlossen habe
also ich glaube viele wissen auch nicht
dass die die ausbildung zum virologe
wirklich auch ein facharzt ist wo auch
die infektionsepidemiologie und
mikrobiologie dazu gehört und man daher
auf solche infektionsgeschehen
abschätzen kann
das war völlig persönlich heute mit
professor hendrik speck herzlichen
dankeschön
[Musik]